Newton's second law states that the sum
of the forces on an object is equal to
the acceleration of that object times
the mass but what if instead this object
is actually two objects do I now need to
consider the forces that are acting
between each of these parts or what if I
consider the object to be made out of
even smaller parts I can take it down to
its smallest components and consider the
interactions between all of the atoms in
the object this seems like an
overwhelming number of forces that I'm
going to need to calculate to just to
find the force on this object but I
never seem to calculate this many forces
why is that all of these forces between
the atoms and the object cancel out
because they are Newton's third law
pairs if both objects are within the
system since a Newton's third law pair
of forces is equal and opposite the
total force is just zero we call these
internal forces that is forces that are
acting between a pair of objects that
are both within our system on the other
hand external forces forces that act on
an object within the system by an object
outside the system are what we need to
consider for our calculation
we could be more precise about Newton's
second law and say that the total
external force on a system is equal to
the system's acceleration times the
system's mass let's look at an example
of how the selection of a system will
affect the forces that we need to
consider I have three blocks I'll call
them one two and three and a force
that's pushing block one to the right
will first take a minute to look at
notation we will write the forces as f12
and this means that it's the force
exerted by an object 1 acting on an
object - in this example I have pairs of
forces between each block the
interaction between blocks 1 and 2 and
the interaction between blocks 2 and 3
let's look at the internal and external
forces on the system if my system is
made up of block 1 and block 2 I have
this external pushing force F external
that's acting from the external pusher
on block 1 blocks 1 and 2 are
interacting with each other but these
are both within my system so these are
internal forces that I do not need to
worry about and finally block 2 which is
within my system is interacting with
block 3 which is outside my system the
external force here is the force that is
acting from block 3 on block 2 now we
know that the two forces that are
relevant to calculating the motion of
this system are the external pushing
force and F 3 - if my system is instead
made up of blocks one and three block
two is now part of the external
environment can you figure out what the
internal and external forces are in this
case the external forces to the system
are the external pushing force F
external F 2 1 and F 2